aaron sampson here looking at the new
scab faction and escape from tarkov
we've enjoyed covering this hardcore
tactical shooter during its development
so tell us if you want more with those
likes and feel free to subscribe to our
channel let's get to it the scab faction
is being added in an upcoming build of
tarkov for a change of pace away from
highly successful hardcore fire teams
currently dominating the game developer
battle state games described in our
interview how scabs can be seen as
complementary to your primary soldier as
a scab you will spawn at random spots on
the map with a random assortment of gear
currently you'll be able to play as this
faction on the order of once an hour or
by paying in-game currency they seem to
serve two purposes one is to collect
gear at no risk to your primary
character and the other is to keep the
main players on their toes as they won't
be able to tell which enemies on the map
Rai and which are player control scab
still have to extract like everyone else
to keep their gear but any gear
extracted goes to the players main
character scabs can also form groups and
interestingly enough may not be attacked
by other ai-controlled scab enemies
battle state t some upcoming editions to
tarkoff coming after the scab update
such as 10 to 15 skills for you to
continuously level through but that can
also fade away if you slack off on the
game and even later T's update may
contain 1 V 1 or 2 V 2 fights between
scavs in an abandoned mall overall
tarkoff is shaping up to be a hardcore
shooter with influences like EVE Online
shaping the developers thoughts on gear
guns and death battle state has put
incredible care into their weapons and
physics systems even going as far as
recording gunfire in some abandoned
Russian warehouses and let's say a less
than authorized manner they seem to be
working on balancing out the fact that
you lose amazing gun building gear every
death with a number of new mechanics
including the scab class a continuous
skill system and a newly mentioned
ability to buy larger Omega safe
containers even ones big enough to fit
rifles you will be able to get these
larger containers through unannounced
future in-game challenges finally devs
mentioned the upcoming insurance system
on weapons in which you get to keep your
custom builds on death assuming it isn't
extracted by another player so what do
you think about the hardcore direction
of tarkov will it fit your high
stakes Daisy h1z1 king of the kill
tactical needs or would you prefer a
game friendlier around the edges bring
your questions Thursday March second at
twelve-thirty pacific standard as we
stream the new scab class with the head
of studio we'll see you then and thanks
for watching